الان من كوفنتري مدير المرصده السوري
لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن سيد رامي
اهلا بك مع اخر المعلومات حول هذا التوتر
الذي تحدثنا عنه شمال سوريا نعم صباح
الخير توتر هو مستمر على ما يبدو هناك من
يدفع هؤلاء الشباب الى المحرقه في محيط
منبج تتحدث نحن
الاقل في اقل من اسبوع نتيجه هذه المحرقه
التي دفع اليها بطلب من جهه ما تحته مسمى
العشائر وهم ليسوا بعشائر عن فصائل الجيش
الوطني وايضا للمفارقه بان هيئه تحرير
الشام تقاتل مع هؤلاء في ريف منبج ان هناك
دفع لاشعال تلك المنطقه اليوم هناك
محاولات جديده كانت من هذه المجموعات امس
كانت بالصوت والصوره وقالوا بانهم دخلوا
وتقدموا واذى بها كامل المجموعه سقطت بين
قتيل وجريح قبلها مجموعه اخرى في كلتمر 24
قتيل منهم لماذا يدفعون هؤلاء الشبان
للمحرقه لا نعلم نتحدث عن 10 فقط ما بين
شمال شرق سوريا وشمال سوريا وشمال غرب
سوريا نتحدث عن نحو 250 قتيل او ما يفيد
في هذه الارتباكات الداميه التي خلقت من
عدم ولم يكن هناك اي اشتباكات في تلك
المناطق قبل ان يعد لها من قبل جهه ما
حقيقه امر
تقول سيد رامي هناك لا تعرف الدوافع هؤلاء
لكن للذين لا يعرفون المنطقه جيدا قد يرون
فيما يحدث ربما
توتر طائفي هل هو كذلك ام لا
يتحدثون بشكل طائفي ولكن في تلك المنطقه
يتحدثون بانهم يقاتلون بعد ذلك يقولون
الاكراد يعني هناك من يريد ان يغذي
النعرات الطائفيه والارقيه داخل الاراضي
السوريه في هذا الوقت بالذات هناك تمديد
اممي ولكن مع الاسف رغم التمديد الاممي
القتل مستمر في سوريا عشره ايام كانت
داميه داميه وامتياز ولكن رغم كل ذلك لا
يتزال التغذيه العرقيه والطائفيه مستمره
من بعض الاعلام الموجود في تركيا او غيره
ما دور النظام السوري في كل ما يحدث
النظام السوري هو المغذي المحرك يعني ما
هذا السر على الاتفاق ما بين الاعلام
المعارض بين الزوجين الموجود في تركيا
واعلام دمشق الذي يغذي الفتنه بشكل كبير
جدا في شرق الفرات لا نعلم ما هذا الود
والوفاق الان في هذا التوقيت بالذات سيد
رامي عبد الرحمن مدير المرسيدا السوري
لحقوق الانسان شكرا لك على كل هذه
التوضيحات